Love is mine 2
[Music]
Ah ah ah ah ah ah jojo 2 cool # Then glaringly, I like Kais, I
like scrap, oh, propaganda, college, fire-resistance, talk,
gather, derma, daily life, I
just have a master right away
Oh so come out
2g no cd I have a langs line
Cool, devilish type, ah, voltage resistance, not cheating correspondent ticket, how do you say,
dry? It's
going to be as good as bloody island Anom Fitz. I've used it all and I'm at the end of the dictionary
.
I can't do this with the aftermath of togo, it's snowing
oo ue
couple uh
[music]
oh oh oh oh
ah so cute
ah green zone zipper cho
what orange ah yes
orange don't want
nose [ __ ] 5 abba rare obviously a little
above  Flakes of Fruit
If it was a purple that was released this time, it's still demi krx bio audition, nothing else, george
anil puck 3 it's probably from 2 o'clock
ah then I'm biting # uh ok uh uh
5 that
yes what
5 company ceo 0 5
open
[Music]
Uh
[Applause
] Uh
I love you yeah
I gave it to you yeah uh